so hi i'm schloss fraser a second year
phd student in computational and
neuroscience so many of you have asked
how i organize my notion for my phd for
collecting research ideas basically
everything i think my whole life is in
notion right now so they have many
templates and i use it personally for
to-do lists habit tracking class notes
teaching basically my entire life so
today i want to give you a walk through
to my notion and really show you how i
use it how i optimize for productivity
habits learning and also kind of give
you an insight into how i structure my
research projects for my phd using my
notion i also want to preface this video
by saying that even though i may seem
quite organized i'm actually extremely
disorganized my way of thinking is not
really linear but more like a graph
structure like and the thing is that my
notion kind of reflects that so i think
my notion is not as aesthetically
beautiful as some of the other people
out there but for me it's extremely
functional and it's the first app that
is kind of so versatile that it kind of
allows me to think in this more creative
way more graph-like structure a instead
of having to organize everything very
neatly so this video was also kindly
sponsored by notion and if after this
video you are inspired to use notion as
well i put the link down below which
allows you to use notion for free and
hopefully you will love it as much as i
do i also included a template of my
personal wiki so if you want to follow
the same kind of structure in your
notion as i use to structure my entire
life you can download that template and
use it for your notion as well but let's
get straight into my workspace so let me
give you an overview of my notion so i'm
looking down by the way because i'm
looking with you at my notion so i can
explain a little bit better so at my
personal wiki the first thing i usually
have is a little quote for that month so
at the moment it is if a little dreaming
is dangerous the cure for it is not to
dream less but to dream more to dream
all the time by marcel prus and this is
just a really nice thing of notion you
can kind of feature or customize every
part of notion to suit your
style so you can for example change the
cover here you can change these kind of
icons i of course put a brain because
i'm a neuroscientist and then the first
thing i did is i created these three
little headers that are for me my
personal values and under these personal
values i put the things that i think or
pages that i think are related to these
personal values and this personal wiki
this template i put down below for if
you don't want to create it yourself you
can also just download that one and put
your own personal values and your own
things in it so the personal values that
i have are wisdom health happiness and
creativity so on our wisdom for me right
now there's my phd of course and
learning and if we look at my phd there
are many pages because this is almost
two years worth um so i'm not gonna dive
into every page because i think that
will take hours and it's not that
interesting for you but i can show you
for example one topic that i was working
on a little while ago was extreme value
theory and you can see here that all the
topics that i researched for extreme
value theory so i looked at theoretical
extreme value theory previous work um
schizophrenia how it relates to
schizophrenia so i can just click on
this and then you see all the research i
did on extreme value theory and this i
made from scratch and it's
seems like a lot of work but as you are
researching and you're slowly filling up
your notion page this actually doesn't
take that much time and it for me really
suits the way i think and the way i
researched so in these pages there are a
lot of backlinks and forward links to
other pages and that for me creates
almost this kind of graph like network
where i can select specific notes
that i want to dive into into my
research
so yeah if we go back to my personal
wiki
under wisdom there's also learning and
this is something that i kind of want to
show you guys how i do this because i
think this is a really cool feature of
notion so you can see on the learning i
just put random topics that i usually
want to learn a little bit more about so
that can be from programming so for
example here to program or researching
here to research and the way i select
these topics is usually i do this with a
special feature of notion and that is
for example in my
so for example in my daily life i'm
spend a lot of time on twitter and i
follow a lot of my favorite researchers
on
twitter and what i do when i scroll down
my twitter if any of my favorite
researchers has uploaded a paper that i
for example want to read so for example
maybe this one it's a paper about
information geometry i don't really know
that much about information geometry so
i click on it and the cool thing down
with notion is what you can do is you
can add this add-on
on google chrome
and with this add-on you can select this
page and save this page to any page you
want in notion
so here you have add to and i
add it to my learning page i click save
page that it has saved
here
and then for example it has already
automatically saved some of the figures
a little bit of the text usually i
remove this but then i have this in my
no status and then usually
if i'm gonna research this topic a
little bit later i put it into research
or reading and then when i finish the
topic i put it in done and that way i
almost use notion as my ideas bank or
like a second brain where i upload all
the information or all the content that
i have found on the internet and this
way i've noticed i almost never forget
anything interesting that i have found
and it's just a really convenient way to
kind of snippet little parts of the
internet that you find interesting and
put them at a designated space without
any extra effort and another cool thing
is it also works for your phone so you
can also do this on your phone and so if
i'm scrolling on my phone on twitter for
example i do the same thing i can share
it and put it on my notion page as well
so that's everything in the wisdom part
then i have health slash happiness i
have reviewed that's how i review my
days and i make a life naive is the city
i moved to so i kind of put some little
nuggets of things that i want to have in
naimei or want to do in naimei so for
example right now i want to do a little
bit more yoga and dance and i put it on
the yoga and dance creativity is also a
big part of my life so for example i can
go to video ideas and these are all the
video ideas i ever thought of for this
channel and i do it almost the same way
as i do the learning thing the learning
page so whenever i find an idea across
the internet i bookmark it and i put it
in my notion page then if i create the
thumbnail or title i put it here when
i'm writing for it
filming so right now these nine videos
are ready to film
and then published and for example i can
show you what i'm writing this is how to
optimize memory skills i usually put
little thumbnails that i kind of like
from other youtubers or youtubers
or movies it can be that i put a little
quote and then here i will write the
script for example
and that's kind of how i do everything
for youtube so that's also
to give you an insight i put weekend
reading that's my reading log and qree
entrepreneur resources that's from ali
abdul that's a page he created follow
him as well by the way he has amazing
notion resources then i have goals so i
make an annual review every year so i
make an annual review every year so this
is the annual review of 2020 2021 and
2022 is coming i can maybe one time show
you how i do the annual review if you
are interested so put it down in the
comments below if you want to see that i
also have an impossible list i think i
got this idea from maybe thomasfrank but
i'm not entirely sure and these are just
goals that i'm not focusing on at the
moment that but that i maybe want to do
in the future because i have a lot of
goals that i would love to do for
example my traveling also i want to go
to greece meteora
ireland cycling portugal hiking and i
just kind of put it here to think like
oh just to remember i also want to learn
chinese at a certain point and relearn
french with linguda i'm actually doing
that right at the moment so that's kind
of cool and sometimes i do certain
things for example hpm in scotland i've
done that um an event in korea i kind of
want to go to a certain learning event
to go back to korea and see some of the
people i know there i also have
meditation as one of my goals i'm not
very good at meditation so if you're
really good at meditation put it down
below how you do it um because i'm still
working on it and then the last section
i have is just life so here are all the
pages that don't really fit anywhere
else so these are gifts that's gifts of
friends and family that i think of
throughout the year um trips and outches
so that's travel things that i want to
do financial diets this is because i'm
inflation so i kind of have to track my
expenses so i downloaded from one of the
templates from notion i downloaded this
expense tracker and that's that
financial diet french that i'm working
on
daily these are daily little logs so
every day i write down three things that
i appreciated of the day and i usually
put it in my notion and passive income
this is something i'm thinking about a
lot lately to create passing income not
only from youtube but i maybe want to
add a certain point to start a company
or do some other things such that i can
create a really cool like research
community and i'm not i'm totally broke
by the end of my research journey so
yeah another thing that i'm really
working on lately is this 12 week year i
got it from this youtuber montelebe so
follow her down below up with a link i
really like her channel and she talks
about 12-week year it's this book that
i've also read and the idea of the
12-week year is that you accomplish
all your goals in 12 weeks instead of
putting it to the end of the year to
kind of accomplish it so i also put the
template that i use down below so you
can also check it out it's partly based
on the template by montelebe so also
check out her template and see if any
one of them suits you so these 12 weeks
i really want to work on wisdom and
that's because i just moved to my
university city so the university city
i'm living at at the moment has a lot of
wisdoms that i think i can tap into
so i usually put a clo quote for the 12
weeks so at the moment it is lived a
wonderful life that is in you by oscar
wilde who is my favorite author probably
so
if you want to read a cool book lately
read a book by oscar wilde so what i
usually do with the 12 week year is that
you think about a goal that you have or
three goals that you have for the year
so for me it was to have a paper
published it's how to have a thriving
website i want to create a website and
grow my youtube channel of course so
instead of having these three goals for
the year you kind of think about how
could i achieve this if i optimized all
my time and resources for the next 12
weeks so you then set your priorities so
for example for me priority one is
finishing in paper and then i have these
strategies and then i think about as
many strategies as possible to achieve
those goals and afterwards i have this
month one which has a daily tracker
where i put daily habits that i would
like to do and if i accomplish those i
would kind of accomplish my 12-week goal
and then i plan for week one week two
week three with the priorities like this
and i put again the template down below
so you don't have to create this
yourself so yeah this is kind of
a short overview of what my notion looks
like at the moment of course if you dive
into all these pages there are many
templates that i've created and many
little
nooks and crannies and ideas one of the
best things
with notion is that it has this
search option so i can just search
everything and one other thing that i do
kind of want to show you is that one
really cool thing that i also like about
notion is that you can also share your
pages so i also work with my students a
lot in ocean so for example one of my
master's students juan we worked i
worked with him on a project a really
cool project i'll put his github down
below if you want to check it and the
thing is that for him i kind of created
this page that we could collaborate on
and that's just also something really
nice about notion that it's just a super
nice place that you can literally do
anything you can collaborate you can
plan your life you can track your habits
you can make your daily affirmations
everything so every time i think of a
new thing that i want to do for example
if i want to track my exercise regime i
will make a page in notion to do that
and this way notion almost becomes like
my second brain i have my first brain
which of course is my real mind to do
all the thinking and a knife notion
which does all the planning habit
tracking
information gathering and that's just
all in one place which i really like
about it so notion is 100 free for
students and educators so you can sign
up with the link down below and i again
want to thank notion for sponsoring this
video and if you have any tips or tricks
for me on how you use your notion i
would love to hear it because i am super
interested in notion and how i can
upgrade my productivity swear and
otherwise see you next week bye